this is an update to a story we've been  covering at EF scientists are now  investigating the shark attack that  killed an American woman in the Bahamas  a biologist says there was likely a  trigger that caused three sharks to  attack 21 year old Jordan Lindsey on  Wednesday scientists say the Sharks were  not behaving normally Lindsey was  snorkeling when she was attacked  something that you all do like what  though things are might have been shum  or something on work you know if you see  fishermen or anybody fishing and you go  snorkeling be careful in that attract  what's terrifying is the Sharks were not  behaving normally but she was behaving  normally I think we all do you know  right doing that is what she was  provoking them no sadly her mother was  just a few feet away it's heartbreaking  yeah